(crowd cheering)
NARRATOR:
It's 1992,
President George H.W. Bush
is up for re-election.
With a squeaky clean image,
he's had some of the highest
approval ratings
of any president.
Then, a political bad boy
joins the race.
(jazzy saxophone music)
AJ BENZA:
Bill Clinton came on the scene.
A young guy,
the next Kennedy,
handsome, charismatic.
ICE-T: Clinton's over here
playing the saxophone.
I'm like, oh,
this dude is smooth.
This dude is a real player.
NARRATOR:
He may be smooth,
but Clinton will need
some serious help
in a presidential race
that promises
to be anything but boring.
CONNIE CHUNG: Scandal wasn't
a new thing in politics,
but nothing was like Clinton
when he was first running
for president
of the United States.
BILL CLINTON:
Come on.
JOE KLEIN:
In the old days,
there was one news cycle
a day. (laughs)
There was the evening news
on television.
KURT ANDERSEN:
Only during Clinton's campaign
did we start getting
the 24/7 news cycle
that previous candidates
didn't have to deal with.
NARRATOR: Clinton needs
a team to stay on top
of the news coverage,
ready to spin the story.
The leaders are
young communications director
George Stephanopoulos...
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS:
That's what the American
people care about.
They wanna move
into the future.
NARRATOR:
...and their greatest weapon,
political consultant
James Carville,
known throughout Washington
as the Ragin' Cajun.
CARVILLE: I've always said
a political campaign
is like you've
kicked down a door,
you don't know
what's behind it.
NARRATOR: Carville's a genius
at political strategy
and keeping the campaign
on message.
CARVILLE: Stay focused,
talk about things
that matter to people,
you know.
It's the economy, stupid.
NARRATOR:
Combative and loud,
he ushers in a new era
of political
hand-to-hand combat,
organized from his war room.
CARVILLE:
The war room was conceived
to deal with...
to compress news cycles
in a coherent
and coordinated way.
GEORGE BUSH SR.:
And I will stand on my record,
and I won't let
that Arkansas governor
run away
from his record either.
(crowd cheering)
NARRATOR:
When Bush attacks,
Clinton's war room ignores
the old tactic
of letting bad stories
blow over
and goes on the offensive.
CARVILLE: What are we gonna do
when George Bush attacks us?
Why can't we attack
George Bush?
NEWS ANCHOR:
Today, Governor Clinton accused
the president's party
of misrepresenting his past.
Here's ABC's Jim Wooten.
CARVILLE:
The idea was to answer somethin'
in a creative,
a provocative way,
that editors would see
and lead with that story.